I also want to congratulate
you on the movie
Eurovision Song Contest:
The Story of Fire Saga.
I watched this last night.
Another enjoyable romp.
I have to tell you I really enjoyed it,
but I didn't know
anything about Eurovision.
The Eurovision song
contest is a real thing
that you've been obsessed
with for a while.
Is that right?
Yes, it is a, it's been
going on for 60 plus years
and every year it's watched from anywhere
to 180 to 200 million people,
and it is one of the craziest
things you'll ever see.
I, I discovered it literally
20 years ago with my wife.
We were visiting her family in Sweden
and we, we, we had had
dinner and all of a sudden
her cousin was like, so
shall we watch Eurovision?
And I was like, okay, yeah, what's that?
And, and sat there for
three hours mesmerized by,
I had no idea what was going on.
It is like Cirque de Soleil
meets American Idol meets,
I don't know, a residency show in Vegas.
It's, it's the craziest
thing you've ever seen.
Also meets the Olympics because
it's different countries
going up against each
other, and one of the things
you capture in this movie
is there is something about
European entertainment
that is a very specific,
and so you, in the movie
you portray people singing
like rock power ballads
dressed as Vikings.
That's something that really
could happen on Eurovision.
100% and it's, it's so
foreign to us as Americans.
You know, we, any sort of
our competitive music shows,
we're, we're, we're pretty much
into looking as cool as we can.
In Eurovision it's quite the opposite,
even though they fully
believe they're looking
as cool as possible, but
yeah, you'll, you'll see
everything from costumes,
a lot of pyrotechnics,
a lot of people just onstage doing nothing
that has anything to do with the song,
(chuckling)
including one of the, I've actually been
to three of them in
person, and one of the bits
that we actually lifted
and put in the movie
was I think, I believe it was the Ukraine
and this, this singer was, was singing,
but behind them on the stage was a man
just running in a life,
human sized hamster wheel
for three minutes and was never
referenced in any way and.
Had nothing to do with the song.
Nothing to do with the song.
The singer didn't look back.
The, they even got a tight shot of the guy
running in a hamster wheel
and he just kept running.
He wouldn't even look at the camera.
♪ My heart is like a clock,
I'm steady like a rock ♪
♪ Shh, don't stop, kiss
and kiss me till I drop ♪
♪ My heart is like a clock,
you wind it with your love ♪
And we were obsessed
with that image that we,
we ended up putting it in the movie.
You know, what I love is that
you're in the hamster wheel
running full out, but unlike
the example you just gave,
you also have to sing while you're running
full out in the hamster wheel.
Looks hilarious and I imagine
was next to impossible.
Well, it is one of those moments where,
and I've found myself on numerous
occasions over my career,
when I read something on the page,
I forget that I'm actually
going to have to do it,
(chuckling)
and there I was on that day
being hoisted about 50 feet
above the ground in a hamster
wheel that I kind of had to
control with my own gait
and then singing the lyrics,
but you know, we got it done.
You got it done.
You got it done in style.
But the, but the prop master did remind me
on several occasions how difficult it was
to build that hamster wheel.
(snickering)
I was like, okay, but isn't that your job?
Yeah, but I'm just telling you there's 97,
there's 96 weld joints alone
on that piece of steel.
All right.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
I think he was looking
for a big thank you.
Thank you. I said thank you.
I could have said thank you more.
I should've sent him Omaha steaks.
You, you reveal that you have
quite a nice singing voice,
Will, and I, it leads me
to wonder what about you
putting out an album, Will Ferrell Sings?
Is that something that could happen?
You know, it could, you never
know, but I would probably
be drawn to more of a spoken word album.
I'd love to bring back spoken word.
You mean, just saying the lyrics.
Saying the lyrics.
Not actually singing the song.
Nope, and not like eight or 10 songs,
30 to 50 songs spoken word.
That's going to be a
very, very long album.
You're going to, you're
going to want to sit back
and really, really be able to dedicate
a nice chunk of time to it.
Yeah, I think you're
gonna want to listen to it
as you drive from L.A. to Boston,
and you're going to maybe
just get through all the songs
maybe as you get to Framingham, Mass.
Exactly.
In fact, I'm going to, that's
how I'm going to do a dry run
where I time it, so when
you pull into Framingham,
you finished the album.
Okay. This sounds like a awful idea.
Thank you.
You've given me a great idea.
No, don't do it.
Wait, what'd you say?
Don't do it. It's a bad idea.
Got it.
No. (snickers)
No. There's a scene in
the movie, you know, I.
No, no.
Don't, don't make your spoken word album.
No, no salute.
No, no one has ever saluted.
Thank you. Conan.
(laughing)
Such a bad idea.